i joining me here in singapore jonathan
chang seoul bureau chief for The Wall
Street Journal and Francesca chambers
White House correspondent for The Daily
Mail I want to talk first about what the
expectations are and what the definition
both sides may look to for
denuclearization heading in Jonathan
what do you think well look this has
been the top topic for the past couple
of months and what's striking here is
that we still don't have a completely
sort of one-to-one understanding of what
exactly is meant by denuclearization
North Korea talks about the complete
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
Donald Trump is talked about and the
u.s. position for a long time has been
CVID complete verifiable you reversible
denuclearization and we could talk for
days if you want about the various
differences between the two of them but
suffice it to say that there are gaps
still and it's unclear whether or not
they've been bridged in the meantime
because we have had a lot of shuttle
diplomacy take place in the last couple
of weeks hopefully they're there closer
to to getting them together but we just
don't know and we may not know until
Tuesday here is Senator Graham and
Gordon Chang this morning on all of this
it's amazing it's a direct result of the
maximum pressure campaign the only
reason North Korea sitting down on the
table with Trump is that they believe
for the first time that they've got
somebody in the White House they don't
know how to deal with and Trump his goal
is to eliminate their nuclear missile
program not contained it and I think
he's got North Korea and China's
attention certainly Kim wants the
photographs of him shaking hands with
President Trump because that's
legitimization and even more important
that means he solidifies his rule at
home because we're gonna see those
pictures of Trump and Kim for decades in
North Korea so you know President Trump
gives up a lot of leverage as soon as he
shakes hands with Kim the Gordon's point
there at the end at the beginning of
this summit Kim gets one of the big
things he wants which is this picture
right and speaking to it Lindsey Graham
also said later on it didn't show here
all that's at stake right is peace or
war he thinks those are the two options
potentially coming out of this if
President Trump doesn't eventually get a
deal with North
to denuclearize and he said we could
talk for days about the definition of
that that's what we hope to - is talking
for days about that now we had Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo refusing to tell
reporters at the White House last week
whether or not how closer they had
gotten on that he said that they had on
the definition but we don't know how
much closer and I have experts telling
me that North Korea doesn't just
consider denuclearization of the
peninsula just the landmass that they
could expect that to extend all the way
to our military presence in Guam and
that's a question as to whether
President Donald Trump in the u.s. is
prepared to offer that I want to read
something from Richard Haass and he
after the g7 back and forth and what
ended up happening there the unraveling
of the g7 summit works in North Korea's
favor he writes as president Trump will
not want to bust up two summits in a row
less people conclude he is the problem
increases incentive for Kim to up his
asks and limit his compromises and for
Trump to do the opposite hardly the
ideal context Jonathan couldn't somebody
look at that and say couldn't it be the
exact opposite that he's willing to just
get up from the table and say this isn't
gonna work and walk away well look I
think there's a case to be made that Kim
can win either way I mean obviously he
gets everything that he wants if he
makes a big ask and gets it that's
that's obviously good for him but you're
right that there is a possibility that
even if things don't go well he can say
look I acted in good faith I hand it
over your three detainees I blew up this
nuclear test site I've been an honest
broker here and if the US isn't going to
play with me then that's their fault
I'm gonna keep my nuclear weapons you
have to admit that the hostages coming
back North Korea at this table the
paradigm has shifted I mean something
changed from all the six-party talks
efforts before to get to this time
President Donald Trump says that would
be him it's because he's here now and
the North Koreans understand that he's
not playing around and it could go the
opposite way if he feels that they're
not serious he said within the first
minute of sitting down he'll get up and
walk away
so breath that's actually an opportunity
potentially for the president to show
his strength here and to show not just
at Kim jong-un but also to Justin
Trudeau the Prime Minister of Canada
that when the u.s. is pushed that
we'll push back and that's something we
heard Larry Kudlow the economic adviser
to the president say this morning too
that they feel that Trudeau was trying
to embarrass President Trump on the eve
of this historic summit and that they're
not gonna let that happen
last thing we just heard from Greg
Powell khat in Seoul obviously Seoul is
watching all of this very closely one
point they wanted to be at the table but
that first meeting is just translators
and the two leaders what is so looking
at and how concerned are they about what
comes out of this well they're concerned
but they're also very hopeful keep in
mind that the president of South Korea
moon jae-in he has invested a great deal
in this whole process somewhat argue
that he's been the one keeping things on
track even when it looked like things
were gonna go off the rails in one
direction or the other and so I think he
understands inherently that with Donald
Trump with Kim jong-un you have a
volatile mix here to be honest we don't
know what's gonna come out of Tuesday I
think people in Seoul are definitely
crossing their fingers though well we
appreciate the early morning now go have
some breakfast thank you for being here